I had no idea what this crime was
or how it could possibly work
Until I started looking into it.
The first we knew about sextortion
was a case in Scotland,
involving a 17-year-old lad
called Daniel Perry,
who had apparently received
messages through Facebook.
He had some money extorted from him.
They received sums of
about 3,000 pounds (US$3,750)
from him before he ran out of money.
They then carried on threatening him,
threatening to release
these video recordings of him.
And they started saying to him
Why don't you kill yourself?
They were taunting him even.
In the last message
he sent to them, he said,
I haven't got any more money, bye bye.
He then took his own life.
When the PNP Anti Cybercrime
Group was created
There were a lot of reports of sextortion
happening in the Philippines,
victimising foreign nationals.
Of course, international pressure
started to build,
especially after the death
of Daniel Perry in 2013,
and the Interpol was involved.
There was one,
I suppose a typical victim,
of a guy in Hong Kong.
He was working in an office
and was approached on Facebook.
And he went off into the office toilets.
He had this exchange with somebody
he thought was a woman in the Philippines.
Two hours later, they were
demanding money from him.
He had to rush out of the office
at the end of the day,
to try and find a Western Union branch
to send over a sum of money.
The next day, another demand came.
He eventually sent about 2,000
to 3,000 pounds, or about US$3,000,
before plucking up the courage
to go to the police and report it.
Usually, these crimes might originate
in Nigeria or some African countries,
and then get copied overseas,
but this was the first that anyone had ever
heard of these crimes being perpetrated.
In around 2013 or 2014,
they suddenly started springing up.
This crime didn't exist
until Maria Caparas invented it.
The ringleader of a group
of young people
who were carrying out
these crimes of sextortion,
extorting money from people
through Facebook
and getting large sums of money out of it.
Her syndicate is thought to have
raked in millions of pounds.
Huge sums of untraceable money,
all of which will be sent
to Western Union accounts.
Some of the Western Union branches
in the area where she lived,
recorded the biggest takings of any
Western Union branches in the world
for a period in 2014 and 2015.
There was so much money
coming in at that time.
This operation was named
Operation Strikeback
which resulted in the crackdown
of the syndicate group
which was involved in sextortion cases.
It was quite big, because
back then, cybersex extortion
or crime was new to us.
It was not that popular yet,
so the impact of the story was alarming.
They were able to track
the movements of money.
All the proceeds were going
to the two Western Union accounts
owned by Caparas and her live-in partner.
I think they were able to seize
a couple of laptops.
Hard disks, sex toys, several
motor vehicles, including wigs
I was told that she was still active
on social media in prison.
I sent her a message, in hope
rather than expectation, saying,
I'd like to hear your side of the story,
would you let me visit you in prison?
She insisted she was innocent,
that another woman in the village
was the real kingpin
and she was being scapegoated.
She almost convinced me.
She told me that she had been
set up, and she was crying.
And I asked her, What do you think
about the men who fall for this?
She said, They're stupid,
they're just stupid. I told them.
I told one or two of them, Don't do it again,
because you've learnt your lesson now'.
She could switch quite quickly,
and was clearly quite a persuasive
and highly confident person.
A sociopath is probably
what you'd describe her as.
But for whatever reasons, we can only
suspect what those reasons might be,
no case ever came to court and
it appears to have simply dissolved.
Caparas is free,
and she got her cars back too.
Maria Caparas first started
working in chat centres
where Filipino women would strip off
and talk to foreigners.
Let's face it, it's a pretty degrading
line of work to find yourself in.
I imagine that's perhaps where her
cynicism about the victims comes in.
She has seen men who are behaving
in a very exploitative manner,
and presumably working with other people
who have been similarly exploited.
It's like a telemarketing office
or a call centre,
but they are selling porn and porn sites.
And once they saw an opportunity
of someone asking for more
At some stage, we don't know when,
but a light bulb went on,
and she realised how she could
turn this to her advantage.
It's an evil scam, but it's a very clever
scam at the same time.
It plays on the fact that people are so ready
to strike up conversations
with complete strangers.
They will use a persona
of a pretty young woman.
The persona used would be
a younger female,
fun-loving, a bit silly, a bit more
of a fun and games approach.
In social media platforms,
most of the information is available.
They can easily go to your profile
and go through the information;
go through your hobbies, your habits,
go through the messages, images,
videos and all the comments,
and know who are your friends.
The main goal for them is to make
the account as real as possible.
Why? Because they want
the victim to trust them easily.
20 years ago, you would never
publish your private image,
or hang it outside your door
so everybody could easily see it.
Because at that time, it was something
that was private information.
We are freely posting
information about ourselves
and just giving it away
to the public and the scammers.
We are just inviting them, and saying,
This is my life. You want to know
anything about my life, here it is.
And you can just have any information
about me on social media.
I believe today, there is a popular trend
where popularity is above privacy.
So, the more popular you are,
the better it is.
But again, as a choice with popularity
and having a public profile,
comes everything that relates
to that and the risks associated.
That's where social platforms
are, in general,
a great platform for criminals
to perform their crimes.
It's an easy way and they can hide
behind different fake identities.
Basically, they use social media a lot.
They would trawl social media websites
and interact with people,
and they are fishing for potential preys.
The way sextortion works is that somebody
will send you a friend request on Facebook,
somebody you've never met before.
If you respond to that chat, then
you can easily be hooked to the chat.
A typical legitimate account has
around 200 to 400 Facebook friends.
Statistically, when we are trying to analyse
the Facebook accounts of criminals,
you would see just around 10 friends.
And they're foreign friends
from everywhere.
It's a scripted narrative they use
that almost always works.
And they have a mastery over the script;
the words to use,
the emotions to show,
the little attentive messages
that you can send every day
that makes somebody feel good.
It is in this climate of trust that
they take advantage of the victim.
We always assume,
like in those Hollywood movies,
somebody extremely skilful who
is running some script and codes.
However, that is just 15% of
what's happening in cybercrimes.
The other 85% of the cybercrime
has nothing to do with technical things,
it's what we call social engineering.
Social engineering is based
on manipulating people,
it is very effective when you create
a certain connection with your victim
and try to use that
in order to achieve your crime.
These were mostly teenage boys, some
of whom were transitioning to be women.
That's the age bracket of the people
who were normally arrested for sextortion
because they know a lot about computers.
You can just pay these jobless teenagers
300 to 500 pesos (US$5.70 to $9.60) a day
and it will be enough for them.
You can easily lure and attract them
to these kinds of sex activities.
Good chatters would get
bonuses and extra rewards.
She would shower them with gifts
like iPhones and Samsung phones.
All the arrested individuals were minors.
The surroundings
is much safer for them,
because there are inadequate police
authorities who operate in the area.
North Hills still looks like
a very ordinary village.
But somebody pointed out to me,
Have you noticed what's
different about this village?
I said, I can't. It looks like
another Filipino village to me.
They said, Look at the kids,
they're all wearing designer t-shirts.
You don't get that in a normal
Philippine village.
She owned a large property
in the centre of the village,
it was like an entertainment centre for the
mostly young people who would work for her.
When we were there, there was always
crowds of kids gathering around,
who were, of course, of a demographic
that would be working for her,
or being primed to work for her
as soon as they were a little older.
If you ask anybody about Maria Caparas,
they suddenly suffer from amnesia
and are reluctant to talk about it.
A shopkeeper who lives near her house says
everybody knows about what's going on
but nobody will talk to you about it.
People are terrified to talk
about what's going on,
not only terrified,
but probably invested as well.
Because everybody has a son,
daughter, brother or sister
somehow involved on one side
of the scam or the other.
With money, you can literally buy people,
and that's technically what she was doing.
Maria Caparas came from
an extremely poor background,
she was living in the slums in Manila.
When she first arrived in the village,
the neighbours told me she was so poor
that she had to beg for a bowl of rice
to feed her and her two children,
she had nothing at all.
She's a Slumdog Millionairess effectively.
She has come from nothing and become
extremely rich in an extremely dark way.
I received a random
Facebook request one night,
from what looked like
an attractive female.
At first I was resistant because
I didn't know this person at all.
At the time, I didn't think nothing of it,
like I said, so we started chatting.
The second that we got onto the webcam,
this person was already
removing their clothing.
I did not anticipate this, it wasn't
that kind of conversation prior to that.
I just thought they wanted to talk.
They started removing their clothing,
started doing some bolder things
with toys and stuff like that.
And then started asking me
to remove my clothing.
I was resistant for a long time,
for maybe about 15 minutes.
I didn't really know this person,
I didn't want to do that.
I'm not really into that whole thing either.
But eventually, I did.
I showed them my private area.
This person proceeded
to stop the video chat.
And the screen went completely blank.
Once that happened, I kind of
realised something wasn't right.
I saw Maria Caparas in prison and she
explained to me actually how it all works.
She says that within 20 minutes,
the chat gets so intimate.
They are pre-recorded videos
controlled by key points.
There is a combination of keys
to have that pre-recorded video play
as if you are really doing it for him.
They don't need to be IT experts or hackers.
Because all this private information
has already been shared
on the social media platforms.
For example, if you have
working experience somewhere,
you have already entered which
locations and company you work for.
They don't only want you as a target,
because all those friends and members
who are on your social media
can be a valuable target to them.
If you can record something
and play it over again,
you are traumatised
each time you see it.
When you are threatened that
these things will be publicly released,
you literally panic,
and you get very upset.
Many of these young people become
very anxious and very depressed.
Whilst you have the teams of young
people running the sextortion racket,
she had another team of people
helping her produce fake ID cards
with which she or her lieutenants
would use to collect the money
from the Western Union branches.
The way it works is that
to collect these transfers,
you just need an ID card that matches
the name on the transfer from overseas.
And in parallel to
her sextortion business,
it appears that Maria Caparas had
a cottage industry producing fake ID cards.
From a money shop
that is part of the syndicate,
it's much easier than withdrawing
the money from a money shop
that is not owned by
or part of the syndicate.
So the syndicate can manipulate
the transaction and the release of money,
but when you trace the money,
the details about the ID is all fictitious.
-It's a fake ID.
-It's a fake ID, definitely.
So, for the last decade or so,
we've been focusing on making
the world more open and connected.
And we're not done with this yet,
we're always going to do this.
But I used to think that if
we just gave people a voice,
and helped some people connect,
that would make the world
a lot better all by itself.
And in a lot of ways, it has.
It's probably the tip of the iceberg.
We find that about 50% to 60% of scammers
do most of their scamming on Facebook.
Facebook is the perfect platform
for the scammers
because everything they need
is in that one place.
They are able to meet with people
and video chat with them there.
They have their lives there,
and their photographs,
and a list of their friends and family,
so it's just all encapsulated
in that one place for them.
I'd say we get around 500 reports a month,
which is about 15 a day.
When we originally started doing this,
around 40% of the people who come to us
say that their scammer
was from the Philippines.
Today, around 55% to 60% of them
would come from the Philippines.
The first requirement for a person to
get involved in sextortion is the internet.
It can be anywhere in the Philippines,
there is no specific location.
They just need very basic things.
Definitely, they need some device.
This syndicate can be anywhere.
They don't need to be in a certain location
to find a victim in that particular location.
They can sit anywhere and
the victim can be far, far away.
There is a continual increase of the
numbers of recorded sextortion cases.
You can see from the statistics that...
there is an increase of 100% per year.
80% of our recorded sextortion
cases uses social media.
There's a huge difference in
investigating a traditional crime,
like a simple robbery, a case
of homicide, or a case of murder.
There is a huge gap, on the
procedure of investigating cybercrimes.
The people do not know or understand that
we cannot just hack into someone's system
and determine who is the person
victimising them.
Another thing is that the social media
administrators are outside the Philippines,
they're not here.
Not days or weeks,
but it took several months
for us to acquire the information
that we sought.
We need a lot of information
to be able to identify
who are the people
behind this cybercrime.
How do we know who
we are talking to in reality?
We are not able to verify that identity
in a way like we possibly could
in the physical world.
There is no need for verification
due to the fact that social media's
priority is user adoption.
They want more users on their platform.
We do not have a worldwide legislation
that can cover those cybercrimes,
and the criminals know that.
In some countries,
they do not even need to hide
because they know that no one
will come and search for them.
Maria Caparas was quite brazen
about the way she operated.
She also posted pictures
of her 13-year-old son,
lying down covered in thousand-peso notes
and lots of other quite overt pictures.
She was very open about
the money they were making.
Celebrating Christmas and
wearing t-shirts with her name on it,
calling them the All Stars North Hills
Village with a logo printed on the back,
showing a thumb with a cross, the sign
you get if you're blocked on Facebook,
and the words We hate this.
I don't think that she personally
sees any reason to stop,
so long as she can continue
getting away with it.
All the signs are that she's going to
carry on getting away with it.
She's the queen of sextortion
and North Hills Village is her fiefdom,
her kingdom, if you'd like.
There's a huge boom in social media
where wildlife trade is concerned.
We started seeing an increase
in the number of people
that were actively participating
on social media forums.
They were interested in
buying and selling animals,
they were interested
in asking about animals,
they wanted to know prices.
We realised that it was
really becoming quite popular.
We identified 14 Facebook groups.
We spent just 30 minutes a day
to figure out what level of activity was
taking place in these 14 Facebook groups.
More than 300 animals
were being offered for sale.
We can say that they were
being offered for sale
because prices were mentioned.
Prices were specifically
mentioned in at least 30 posts.
For just these 30 animals,
the cumulative value was
about RM184,000 at that time.
I think this really boils down
to an issue of demand and supply.
As long as there is a demand,
the supply will consistently be there.
The Wildlife Department
has got its hands full.
We have been doing the best we can
in trying to curb this illegal trade.
But now, the illegal traders
have become very savvy.
They have gone into cyberspace,
and they are selling their products
in cyberspace.
Of course, with the advent of Facebook
and advertising on the internet,
they are able to spread the information.
And as always, when there are buyers,
there will be people who will break the law
in order to try and gain a profit
by selling animal parts and species
that are quite precious to us.
It's really quite sad, because
you hear a baby crying.
Somebody is obviously
videoing this whole experience.
The box arrives,
the box is opened,
and a little baby in the box is just wailing.
All you hear is a wail.
It's about a baby animal
that is stolen from the wild.
It doesn't belong in a box,
it doesn't belong in a small box.
It would have been shipped by post,
and it had no right to be in that position.
When you look at history, it was
the rich and famous or the royalty
that used to showcase their animals.
It was always linked with prestige,
status, and being somebody.
If I can show that I own this animal,
then I now become a person
of prestige, status,
and acquisition.
It is part of my wealth and
part of my trophy right now.
The royalties, the kings and queens,
would then feature these animals
because everybody
was curious to see them.
It's probably one of the early
precursors of zoos.
They used to feature these animals,
and people would come to observe them.
There was a process where they would
show these animals to their friends
and they would publicise it.
In the social media world,
it means I'm going to get more likes.
Especially if you have
a cute, fuzzy little animal
that everybody is very excited about.
You're going to get a lot of friends
coming to your page and liking it,
and it goes viral.
This is one of the ways that people
are making themselves more famous
by linking themselves up
with exotic animals.
To the buyer, that is somehow appealing.
It gets posted online, and
gets a lot of likes and comments.
Of course, there are a lot of angry people
who say that this is not right.
But clearly, that's not
what matters to the buyer.
Social media and online platforms
have obviously made it really easy.
Because now, by using this technology,
they can easily target the mass market.
They can publish a product,
and everybody can know it
in a split second.
All these platforms
do have terms and conditions.
It says in the terms and conditions that
you cannot have any illegal activities.
This is very clear to the public.
However, obviously,
these people misuse the platform.
At in the same time,
you can communicate with them.
All these platforms provide a facility
to have a secure and private chat.
That makes it more difficult for
investigators to access these chats
and to identify the right person
behind the animal trafficking.
For instance, by using encryption,
you can easily engage in a private chat.
As you know, it's impossible
to break the encryption.
The biggest challenge is data privacy,
and how the platforms make
the data or communication private.
Everybody is operating under the cover
of being behind their computers or phones,
it's not always easy to identify
where these individuals are.
Is this illegal?
Which are legal and illegal?
How do you know that these animals
are brought in illegally?
For some of the illegal trade,
they are really pretty expensive.
The value is equivalent to the downpayment
for a small house in Malaysia.
We're not talking about RM10 or RM20,
we're really talking about hundreds
and thousands of ringgit.
The Malayan Tiger is very specific,
in a sense that it's only found
in Peninsular Malaya.
We are putting in a large effort
to conserve the tigers in Malaya,
we only have less than 200 of them.
But as you know, tiger parts trading
is now a worldwide market.
People come here just to look for tigers,
to set up snares and catch them,
because a tiger can be sold for
between US$150,000 and US$200,000.
Every part of the tiger is sold
to make a profit.
In our jungles, there are people
from Vietnam, Cambodia and Laos,
including locals, who are hunting them.
The batch of ivories confiscated consists of
3,692kg of whole and partial tusks,
and 228kg of semi-finished products.
These tusks are heavy.
Of course, these are beads
made out of the tusks,
they are not that heavy,
but these tusks are heavy.
This is machine-cut.
We are going to show you how smugglers
commonly smuggle things on their persons.
This is the most common
when they are travelling by air.
For example, this is an egg vest.
People have been caught trying
to smuggle eggs on themselves,
sometimes it is on their body,
sometimes it's strapped on their legs.
It keeps them nice and warm,
and doesn't set off any metal detectors,
so the process goes through
quite smoothly.
Sometimes there are also these
specially modified vests or jackets.
In here, this is a fake ivory, of course.
There are additional pockets.
You can carry almost anything
as long as it's not metal.
It won't set off the metal detectors.
If you add more layers of clothing,
you get a little puffy
and you won't set off any alarms.
This is an example of how
tortoises are frequently smuggled,
they are taped to prevent
them from moving.
Every single one of them are alive
because they are for the pet trade.
Another example are birds in bottles.
If you go online and Google it,
you'll find many pictures of birds
being smuggled like this.
It has holes to let them breathe,
but it is one of easiest and
fastest way to smuggle birds.
Who doesn't like a book?
But inside, there is a gecko.
These are actual examples of how
smugglers have been arrested.
We are seeing a lot of our native animals
being exported for sale
somewhere else in the world.
We're also seeing non-native animals
coming into the country,
so there are these dynamics
as a source and as a consumer,
as well as a transit country for things
that aren't really targeted to local demand.
We're not saying that
this is a problem in Malaysia,
this is a global problem.
We have found baby gibbons
We found baby sun bears
It's really quite shocking.
They were animals that were
considered to be totally protected
under the Wildlife Conservation Act
of Peninsular Malaysia.
A number of these individuals
are actually offering animals
that you are not allowed to sell.
The more worrying question is, how did
these individuals get these animals?
The vast majority of them
were native animals,
which means that people were going
into the forest and trapping them.
What's really surprising and
even more shocking about this
was that almost all of them
were juvenile animals.
Particularly for mammals,
it is a really serious problem.
When you take a baby away
from its mother and its family,
you don't know
how long they will survive.
Their own support system in the wild
has essentially been taken away.
They had no respect for
protecting species in the wild,
they had no respect for law
enforcement and the authorities.
It was a crime, clear and simple,
because they knew for a fact
that they were offering animals
that they were not supposed
to offer for sale.
World Wildlife Day.
I'm declaring war against the poachers.
The time has come to stop
the killing of the Malayan tigers
and other wildlife
by the ruthless poachers.
We have continuous programmes,
whereby a special committee
has been set up
and whatever information
that we have managed to pick up.
Our Cyber Crime Unit knows how goods are
being transferred from one area to another,
that is when we call them in.
We also have help
from international agencies
who have experience in this
and are advising us.
That will deter them from coming in
and trying to poach
our animals from the forest.
We need to change these laws to make them
in line with what is happening today,
and to make sure
that there is a deterrent.
For those who break the law,
the punishment is equally severe
and that they won't attempt to do it.
These laws are in place,
and I think by 2020,
we would see a lot of
amendments taking place,
as far as the ministry is concerned.
My message to them is:
"We are coming, be prepared."
We have given orders on what to do.
If you're caught,
you will pay heavily
for the crime that you have committed.